so this is
just a piece of graffiti this is now
commonplace in portland what it says
is kill a cop for fun and it has
a picture of a smiley face underneath
it is not uncommon to see sentiments
like this the idea
that police are deserving of being
murdered we also see a graffiti like
this about andy know
a journalist not recently but i believe
a journalist was actually
uh assaulted last night if i understood
what i saw on twitter
correctly a portland journalist but um
in any case
you have people telling you what they're
actually about
right this protest if you were
protesting something
important and somebody else in your
protest was saying kill cops for fun
then you would distance yourself so that
your important point
wasn't lost in an obviously crazy point
um and yet that does not happen we have
the mixture of all of these
um things together and they uh result
in people being able to find what they
want those who want to see these
riots sympathetically can find
sentiments that they resonate with
and those who want to see the whole
picture find chaos because it's an
incoherent
set of statements and frankly anarchism
is so much at the root of this
anarchists who
in the aftermath of you know after
protesting and claiming that this was
all driven by
donald trump as soon as joe biden won
we saw them attack the democratic
headquarters and proclaim we are
ungovernable and the answer is look
you are ungovernable the rest of us are
not ungovernable we wish to be governed
well
and you it's not yours to say whether
any of us get good government
right good government is essential if
you don't understand that and you're
going to violate the law then you need
to pay the price and
what we have in this city is
we have corporations and city government
that are coddling these crazy beliefs
we have businesses that you know
at you know are regularly
trying to get vandals to move on to
someone else which of course puts
someone else
in the crosshairs and then we have well
but it's it's
not in the purview of any small business
to uh
obliterate the vandals you know that's
that's the government's job right
it's the government's job and the point
is we in portland who understand that
governance
is necessary are a majority certainly
right we're not all insane and the
problem is it has become hard to say
that we need good governance that we
need policing it needs to be good but
yes we need policing no don't defund
don't abolish
right these things are necessary to a
functional um
society and so what we are now seeing is
what happens
when you try to appease crazy people who
don't understand the basics and you know
we're getting unfortunately
what we collectively ordered and yeah
and it's i mean it's it's
going to get terrible again like i mean
this this is bad enough but it's going
to get terrible again like it was last
summer
in part for the same reasons that it
happened last summer and forget their
cover story forget
like oh it's going to be the chauvin
trial verdict it's going to be this
that you know some you know that's all
cover story yep
it's all cover story the fact is we have
a lot of people who are dispossessed
who have who have no cannot see a way
forward in the world in which they will
be productive
and interested and interesting and
whether or not they
recognize of that um it is a combination
of an economy that is not serving people
and crazy loads of student debt and
credit card debt
and many people have been medicated into
oblivion so they can't even recognize
what their own moods are
and they're on their damn phones all the
time and they're just
stuck in a hellscape
from which they cannot escape and now
the lockdowns continue there are going
to be
seemingly almost no live events through
the northern hemisphere summer
that's two summers in a row with no
outlets
no no festivals no concerts
no ability to get together and have fun
and brawl and all well okay guess what
we're gonna do then
we're gonna do the thing that the health
experts have said
is reflective of the actual pandemic
which is systemic racism
these people aren't about systemic
racism some of them originally and i
mean you've
you as as you revealed in your
conversation with brittany king
and as you revealed in your
conversations with uh jeremy lee quinn
um you know this is a whole mishmash of
of people
but neither you nor i have said about
what is happening
right now in portland or has been
happening in this last week these are
protests that became riots as we said
about this what was happening all of
last summer right because those were
regular protests and for the most part
we didn't think the protests
made a ton of sense but they were good
faith and
some of them many of them were actually
about you know real heartfelt sentiment
and desire
for real honest good change but reliably
like clockwork every night in portland
they became riots
and this that's happening right now this
isn't doesn't even have a pretense yeah
it's not even pretending to be protest
so to be clear about it two things came
together last summer right we have a
long-standing
fringe anarchist movement yeah that has
been very active in the pacific
northwest for a long time
all the way uh wto and and long before
that
yeah um so what's that like 99 or 2001
one of those two
something something in that neighborhood
but um
it fused with black lives matter last
summer
in the george floyd protest era and so
you know for a while it was sort of
cloaked in this
uh this excuse and now you know the two
things have more or less parted ways
and here what we do now is we just skip
right to the right
without you know any meaningful
explanation i do want to
correct one thing though you said um
that it's going to get worse
it doesn't have to it's going to get
worse because we are going to do the
same thing that leads it to get worse
the thing that apple did which now apple
has been punished for for coddling this
sentiment
right that thing results in it getting
worse the
treating these crimes lightly uh
not arresting people when you do arrest
they arrest them
setting low bail the fact of the
population creating a bail fund in which
people who
uh vandalize businesses are
then legally supported by the public and
even frankly i have to say
zack could you put up the picture of the
volunteer this morning
i wanted to do something before that
neither is that there we go
so this is one of of many
uh volunteers who are cleaning up
the streets of portland this morning as
they do reliably can we actually so i
really wanted to finish with that before
we go into talking about the schools
okay
very quickly can we just do one thing
first um zach
you had in the in the pictures that you
were showing that you said were from me
um something that's a picture that said
united by love can you put that up
um so this was outside this is you know
these are the fancy stories in downtown
portland
and um this i think was a tiffany store
maybe i'm not sure i didn't this
united by love and then the next one
which is right next to the composition
on that photo is
excellent thank you thank you um um
the next one should have been
okay okay so the pictures that you've
shown you need to find the pictures
of the women's faces um that have been
vandalized
that were right next to that were part
of the tiffany store i don't know if
they're in mine
i have i sent it to you so i'm going to
describe them for those of you listening
um there is an array of photographs
there we go
no that's it those are them um
of and this is yeah it's tiffany uh and
it's women
it's it's white women and women of color
and um
right next to this united by love sign
and all of the white women have had
their faces xed out
um except there's one white woman in
profile who they didn't get i think they
just didn't recognize her as human or
something they their algorithm didn't
work
it may be how they understood she
identifies yeah
probably so so um united by love you say
so this you know this elite
brand right like i don't i don't know if
i've ever even been in a tiffany's
um i mostly know of it from the
the hamming someone hemingway who who is
it the film
oh uh hepburn not tammy way audrey
hepburn in breakfast at tiffany's
um but united by love and then we see
that um
it's it's only people with skin
of a particular color and that
i don't know that reminds me of eras in
which there's been no love uniting
people
at all and it didn't um it doesn't it
doesn't strike me as about inclusion
or diversity or equity much no
no it's not much one irony after the
other yeah
so now um i i had started seeing
actually in my pictures you can show
zach as well and i guess dad has some
too there were all these volunteers
um showing picture
all these volunteers uh picking up trash
um because our
sky-high taxes in the city of portland
um
apparently can't cover trash cleanup
after riots
we have to we have to bring in
volunteers and these volunteers
were to a person you know seemed lovely
and they were doing
they were doing work that needed to be
doing that needed to be done
and um why why are we using volunteers
not only why are we using volunteers but
there is something about the way
portland cannot prevent a riot but
it is right on cleaning up and trying to
minimize the appearance of the riot
the day after and this has been going on
you know for
you know since since the beginning of
the george floyd
riots last year and we could smell
solvent some places we were walking
where they had already cleaned up a
bunch of the graffiti right this morning
right they they have a mechanism for
cleaning this stuff
up and the point is what part of you
doesn't understand that it is your
obligation
to prevent this and yes clean up that
which you cannot prevent
but you know doing whatever spending
whatever including the labor of people
who are not being paid
to clean up you know presumably
portland's best citizens volunteers who
are willing
to make downtown nicer in such a
terrible circumstance
are paying the cost of portland's worst
citizens
who frankly have told us what they want
to do they want to burn it all down they
don't believe in
any of this stuff they don't believe
that there are rules that can work
they've told us they don't get it right
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to leave the cost
to you know the most benevolent among us
um to to deal with the vandals rather
than
you know support the police in doing
good
police work and arresting people who
harm portland and its citizens i mean
it's just so obvious
you might again this should not be we
should not be required to say this
but supporting the police and their
ability to do good police work
can and i believe should include
restricting some of what the police are
currently doing which they shouldn't be
doing
and actually getting mental health
professionals
to be able to respond to actual mental
health calls as opposed to having police
be first responders for all manner of
calls including ones
for which they are neither trained nor
is it the best use of their time
so unfortunately that that proposal
has often been trotted out as a
replacement for police
and that's insane just as frankly
it's insane to have police doing all of
the work some of which would be better
done
by by mental health counselors right or
you know i don't even i don't i don't
know this you know this is not my
purview but
clearly there are at least two and
probably many more
sorts of work that need to be done and
at the moment the police force is being
forced to do all of it
and of course now it's being forced to
do all of it on a shoestring budget
with hemorrhaging of the police force
because of course good police are
running away
of course they are yeah really they're
in a no-win situation
and you know i've talked to police about
the fact that people are literally
calling for their heads
burning them in effigy etc and
you know i must say they
appear to be unaffected by this and just
treat it as oh yes that happens
on the other hand you know what a
terrible thing
to have this job and to have
good policing declared impossible and
all police declared
guilty by a bunch of people who know
nothing right yeah that just
it's it's an appalling way to treat an
essential uh
function of society and um and you know
the disaster here is just is too
[Music]
predictable
[Music]
you